>> Sean: MORE REACTION TO
TONIGHT'S MONOLOGUE, AND
AMERICA'S FIRST ACTION SENIOR
ADVISOR, SEAN SPICER, AND THE
AUTHOR OF A BRAND-NEW
BEST SELLER, SPYGATE, FORMER
SECRET SERVICE AGENT.
SEAN, I KNOW YOU WENT THROUGH A
LOT WHEN THE PRESS SECRETARY,
AND WORDS ARE ONE THING, BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE LEADERS -- THE
FORMER CANDIDATE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SAYING, WE
CAN'T BE CIVIL WITH THEM.
WE HAVE THE FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE USA
SAYING, KICK THEM?
IF THEY GO LOW, WE KICK THEM?
THEN WE HAVE MAXINE WATERS
SAYING, YOU SEE THESE CABINET
PEOPLE AND YOU GET A CROWD AND
YOU FOLLOW THEM INTO GAS
STATIONS AND GROCERY STORES.
YOU SAW THAT FROM PAM BONDI,
SECRETARY NIELSEN AND TED CRUZ,
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO GET KILLED
HERE.
BUT THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AND HE SHOT UP BY A OF HOUSE
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS.
I THINK THE CONCERN, IT ALL
SEEMS TO BE WORKING IN ONE
DIRECTION.
INSTEAD OF DENOUNCING IT, YOU
KNOW THE MEDIA WOULD BE OUT
THERE ASKING THE RIGHT TO DO
THAT, AND THEN YOU SEE IT
DOUBLING DOWN.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DOUBLING DOWN
AND INCITING IT, AND IF THIS WAS
THE RIGHT DOING IT TO THE LEFT,
IF THESE WERE DONALD TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, THEY WOULD BE
OUTRAGED ON EVERY ONE OF THOSE
LEFT-WING CABLE SHOWS THAT WE
SEE TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
IT'S OUTRAGED -- >> Sean: GO
AHEAD AND FINISH.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, I'VE
NEVER SEEN SUCH A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
THEY JUSTIFY THE ACTIONS ON THE
LEFT, HE IS ALL THE COMMENTATORS
HOSTS ON CNN SAYING PLEASE DON'T
CALL IT A MOB, WHICH IT CLEARLY
IS.
>> Sean: HOW DARE WE SAY IT'S
A MOB.
>> YES.
>> Sean: "THE NEW YORK POST"
ACTUALLY SAID, THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WANTED.
NOT ONLY PORTLAND LAST WEEKEND
AND THIS WEEKEND BUT NEW YORK
THIS WEEKEND AND A BUNCH OF
ANARCHISTS WHICH GO TO THE
NEW YORK G.O.P. CLUB, REPUBLICAN
CLUB OR WHATEVER IT HAPPENS TO
BE.
THEY ARE MEETING VANDALISM AND
ANARCHISTS, SIGNS THAT THEY ARE
PUTTING UP ET CETERA AND THEN
THERE'S A CONFRONTATION ON THE
STREET THERE.
I'M KIND OF PIT STOP THAT I EVEN
BELIEVE FOR A SECOND WHAT THEY
WROTE.
THIS IS COMING FROM THE RADICAL
LEFT, BUT LOOK AT ALEC BALDWIN,
THE LOWEST RATINGS IN THE
HISTORY BASICALLY OF ANY NETWORK
TELEVISION.
IT'S NEVER BEEN THAT LOW.
OR MICHAEL MOORE'S MOVIE.
DOES THIS TRANSLATE TO THE
BALLOT BOX IN 22 DAYS?
>> WE ARE ALREADY SEEING SOME OF
THE RESULTS OF THAT.
WE ARE SEEING A RAISE CLOSING IN
MICHIGAN.
JOHN JAMES, AN INSURGENT
CANDIDATE.
>> Sean: I THINK HE'S A
ROCK STAR.
I LOVE HIM.
>> IS GREAT, IS VIDEOS ARE
TERRIFIC.
TWO QUICK POINTS.
THE LEFT'S RELIGION AND STATE
POWER, THAT'S THEIR RELIGION.
WHEN THEY LOSE STATE POWER, THEY
HAVE NOTHING TO FALL BACK ON.
THEY ARE SOCIALISTS AND THEIR
RELIGION, THEY GENUFLECT AT THE
ALTAR STATE POWER.
>> YOU KNOW HOW THEY LIED AND
THEY DISSEMINATED FALSE
INFORMATION.
ALL THE PHONY DOCUMENTS LEAKED
BEFORE THE ELECTION, AND THEN IT
WAS USED TO SET UP THE WHOLE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
MAXINE WATERS SAYS TO ME, DON'T
SAY IT.
WE WILL DO IT BUT DON'T SAY IT.
NOW THE CENTER FOR
AMERICAN PROGRESS,
JOHN PODESTA'S GROUP, THEY ARE
NOW OUT THERE SAYING DON'T TALK
ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
DON'T TELL PEOPLE WHAT YOU
REALLY WANT TO DO.
SO FOR THEM TO WIN THEY HAVE TO
LIE AND HIDE WHO THEY REALLY ARE
WHICH IS A PRETTY REVEALING
INSTANCE.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE TAPE OF
PHIL BRED A SIN.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT A CANDIDATE,
IT'S CALLED THE PEOPLE OF
ARIZONA CRAZY.
ALL OF THESE TAPES START
UNRAVELING ABOUT HER TALKING
ABOUT IT BEING OKAY TO JOIN THE
TALIBAN.
>> Sean: LET'S GO BACK.
>> THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD
WITH HOW THEY COVER THE RIGHT
AND HOW THEY COVER THE LEFT.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS TALK
ABOUT THE STYLE AND SUBSTANCE
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE
CANDIDATES OR THE RESULTS
BECAUSE IF THERE IS EITHER
ECONOMIC POLICY OR FOREIGN
POLICY.
THE PRESIDENT IS GETTING THINGS
DONE AND THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T BE
WHAT HE'S GETTING DONE.
>> Sean: I SEE THINGS MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH THE
SENATE, SEAN SPICER, BUT IN THE
HOUSE IT'S TOO HARD TO TELL.
>> IT'S GETTING CLOSE.
>> IT'S CLOSER, BUT ARE YOU
CONFIDENT THAT THE HOUSE?
>> A WHOLE LOT OF THEM WILL
BE -- THEY STOP THE AGENDA DEAD
IN THEIR TRACKS.